[Music]
kingdom of bhutan
some of our most important magic has its
origins there they say if you listen
carefully enough the past whispers to
you
[Music]
the world as we know it is coming undone
things that seem unimaginable today
will seem inevitable tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
i imagine that you're all wondering why
you find yourselves here
from this moment forward each of us has
been assigned a role to play
if we're to defeat renuka you'll have to
trust me even when every instinct tells
you not to dumbledore said i give you
something jacob
are you kidding me right now
what are you doing is madness
with or without you i'll burn down their
world
we really intend to turn you back on
your own kind
rescuing me are you
oh well done
[Music]
i have to save the world are we not to
worry
you'll be
today
how will we fulfill our destinies and
transform the world
the secrets of dumbledore
you're not swiveling properly i'm
swiveling out you're traveling it
i don't believe you are rated pg-13 only
in theaters friday
[Music]
you